Let's talk about how to become a leader of Catholicism.
And the Pope who led the billions of believers
Here are the requirements you need to have this high status:
First, it is a Catholic
Second, male
This seems a bit easier... although technically possible on an ordinary Sunday
Catholics have become popes, but this has never happened before.
Because becoming a pope is not like being a president, you are not just for public office.
The pope was chosen by a group of cardinals not publicly decided, although in theory they
You can choose any Catholic male believer to become the Pope. In fact, they will choose one of the cardinals.
Become a pope.
The last time it was not a cardinal and became a pope was more than 600 years ago. So although it is not
The official request is an unofficial official request. (become a cardinal)
Therefore, before you become a pope, you first need to be a cardinal master, and this requires
You step by step to climb the Catholic business class. *
The first step: become a priest. Unlike other churches here you can be on the web
Fill out the form and prove acceptance of the priesthood. To become a true priest in the Catholic Church,
You need professional training. So you need a lot of education
Usually a college degree in Catholicism and then a master's degree in theology.
In addition to your academic credentials, you must also be:
Man is unmarried
Willing to remain single forever. † If you meet these requirements, and have
In the work of the church, then you can formally become a priest. This basically means
You take care of a Catholic church or work with another priest.
However, if you want to go further, you need to climb up to stand up to your priesthood.
That position.
Step 2: Becoming a bishop is a more specifically selected group
Although there are about 400,000 Catholic priests around the world, there are only about 5,000 bishops.
Although the priest has a church, the bishop is the cathedral (bishop's church), which supervises the local from the cathedral.
Some churches.
To promote your class, you must wait for the bishop in your area to be 75 years old.
Or the reason for the death is forced to retire and the job is created for you.
But you can't apply directly, because there is a list of secret bishops.
This list is decided by the current bishops in your area who are updated every three years.
a good successor who can replace them
In order to be listed on the list, in addition to the most obvious requirement of a devout person, you should
and also:
At least 35 years old, the priest has been at least five years old.
Have a theology (or equivalent) doctoral degree assuming you have these things, your name
Maybe but not necessarily on the secret list. Local bishops will give the list to your country
The ambassador of the pope is the ambassador of the Holy See.
The Holy See ambassador selected three priests from the list, in-depth study and interviews
And choose the one he thinks is the best.
But it is not over, because the Holy See ambassador will send his report to the Vatican City and examine it there.
The main parliament from the world's list of bishops
If the bishops do not like any of the three candidates, they can tell
The Holy See ambassador redo once: Return to the primary election list and choose another three candidates
More research, more interviews and delivery results.
When the Bishops Conference is satisfied with one of the candidates for the election of the Holy See
That name will be given to the Pope, and the Pope will be able to reject the candidate and then go through the process again.
So it’s not surprising that the replacement of a bishop’s job may take several months.
And sometimes, for years.
But suppose the bishop in your area is retiring (or dying), just now you are also
Good priest's secret list and the Holy See ambassador pick you up, you also have an interview through him
Then the bishop's assembly approved your pope and did not veto you.
Congratulations! You become a bishop
But you have not yet become a pope. The penultimate action is...
The third step: become a cardinal (cardinal). Despite the fancy name and the stylish red dress match
Cardinal is not the epistle of the bishop, they are also bishops, just a few extra
The most famous job title and more responsibility is to elect a new one.
Pope. ‡
The only way to become a cardinal is to let the current Pope appoint you as one of them.
And 5,000 bishops, only about 200 were former cardinals.
But suppose you are not discouraged by being ignored by the Pope and he finally makes you a Cardinal
Now it’s your turn to play the game waiting for the Pope’s death or retirement.
And the pope is usually dead....
When any situation occurs, the cardinal under 80 will be taken to the Vatican City.
They want to be isolated from the world by taking their phones and tablets
And the pigeons. Once the seizure is completed, the new pope election can begin.
These elections will never be exactly the same because the former pope left behind
He wants to choose the description of the successor, but in summary the principle of operation is this:
Four times a day, Cardinal goes to the Sistine Chapel to vote for one of the Popes.
Get a 2/3 majority vote.
There is a key that can't be too fast. Here the cardinal is not raising a hand to vote.
Or use a modern excellent election system, but on a piece of paper
Write down the name and stand in front of the altar before the official vote
Read a long Latin
Once all the cardinals have finished, click on all the tickets and burn them again.
This is why TV News Channel uses the super-tech HD live broadcast camera to report the pope’s election.
Pat the chimney. If the smoke is black, there is no new pope.
The high threshold and the slow voting process, which is why it takes so long
To choose the new pope. Usually at least four times a day
One Saturday (one day prayer) and lasts two weeks, but the longest record lasts for three years.
Suppose you end up winning the support of a cardinal companion. You have one to do before becoming a pope.
The last thing: take a new name for yourself
There are no formal rules, you can name it yourself.
But traditionally the names of the previous popes were taken.
Once you confirm your name (Princess is over), the ballot is finally burned to make the smoke
It was white and announced to the world that a new pope was chosen.
So integrate the career path: birth is male
Become one of the one billion Catholics, become one of the 400,000 priests, become one of the 5,000 bishops, and become another
One of the 200 cardinals, waiting for the current Pope to die or retire, and persuading 2/3 of the cardinal
The companion chooses which one you are, the only pope.